es la foto de familia después de las
elecciones de medio término de noviembre
son los miembros de la cámara de
representantes que este martes toman
posesión definitivamente en el congreso
la mayoría son republicanos después de
quitarle el control de la cámara baja a
los demócratas tras dos años de mayoría
Y aunque el presidente biden mantiene la
mayoría en el senado y el poder de veto
sobre las leyes que salgan de la cámara
de representantes los republicanos
pueden marcar agenda aunque han hablado
de hacer juicio político contra Joe
biden parece que el primero por el que
Irán será el secretario de seguridad
nacional Alejandro mayorcas por su
manejo de la frontera entre Estados
Unidos y México también quieren hacer
investigaciones sobre la gestión de la
pandemia e incluso citar a declarar a
Hunter biden hijo del presidente por sus
negocios personales en el extranjero
otra baza que tendrán será jugar con el
techo de la deuda es decir el dinero que
el gobierno puede pedir prestado al
tesoro este necesita del apoyo de los
legisladores también presionarán como
han dicho ya para no dar un cheque con
el apoyo económico a Ucrania que hasta
el momento suma 65.000 millones de
dólares y amenazan con condicionar Los
sueldos de funcionarios del gobierno y
el dinero que reciben los departamentos
Joe biden tendrá dos años para defender
los logros de su mandato en asuntos como
infraestructuras cambio climático la
condonación de la deuda estudiantil o el
subsidio a los medicamentos sin embargo
proyectos más importantes como cambios
en las leyes electorales o la
codificación de los derechos de las
mujeres tendrán que esperar eso cuando
Nancy pelosi Se despide del liderazgo de
la bancada demócrata después de dos
décadas